bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne à les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale les sénateurs auditionnent des
représentants des branches françaises de
google ou encore amazon
ces géants du net qui déclarent leurs
revenus dans des pays où la fiscalité
sur les entreprises est plus avantageuse
ainsi il échapperait en partie à l'impôt
sur les sociétés ou encore la tva
google france selon des informations de
l'express seraient ainsi menacés d'un
redressement fiscal de 100 millions
d'euros pour des revenus non déclarés
entre 2008 et 2010 tout de suite donc
direction à la salle clémenceau
poursuivre ses auditions bon après midi
à tous mes chers collègues nous
accueillons monsieur marc mossé
directeur des affaires publiques et
juridiques de microsoft france
et monsieur jean marc tassetto directeur
général avec monsieur olivier esper
directeur des relations
institutionnelles de google france
je vous rappelle messieurs que
conformément aux termes de l'article 6
de l'ordonance 17h58 relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre audition doit se
tenir sous serment et que tout faux
témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 400 34-13 et 400
34-15 du code pénal en conséquence je
vais vous demander de le prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité pour ce faire vous avez levé la
main droite et dira je le veux je le
joue très bien je vous remercie
donc je vous propose de commencer
l'audition par un exposé liminaire
pour ceux et après nous vous répondrai
aux questions du rapporteur et des
autres membres de la commission d'entrée
tantôt me suis bloqué je propose à
monsieur testé tous deux commencé là que
vu qu'ils étaient les consignes en scène
votre marque et j'y ai ma commune c'est
pour ça très bien on va voir on va
apprendre des choses c'est bien ça va
comme une marque
c'est une publicité quand même nationale
je sais le reporter pour marc lieb
l'arrêter c'est à monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs une version de
cette invitation de vente cette
commission d' enquête qui va nous
permettre de mieux exposer la situation
de google france en toute clarté en
toute précision et en particulier la
raison d'être de google france par
rapport à l'organisation global google
je te dire que c'est la troisième fois
que nous intervenons sur des sujets
proches et nous sommes évidemment bien
conscient de la nécessité d'échanger au
maximum sur les enjeux liés à aux
impacts de la révolution digitale qui a
ceci de particulier c'est qui est une
révolution extrêmement rapide et qui
impacte l'ensemble des sujets c'est donc
une révolution structure j'ai souhaité
que olivier esper qui est directeur des
relations institutionnelles de google
france ne m'accompagne pour répondre
aussi précisément que possible à vos
questions nous le ferons dans la mesure
de nos compétences et responsabilités au
sein de google france nous avons bien
noté que le thème de votre commission
denquête et la lutte contre l'évasion
des capitaux ces incidents sur la
fiscalité
nous y répondrons
sous l'angle d'une filiale qui dirigent
des opérations en france filiale d'un
groupe international
c'est à dire que nous ferons un passage
par nos enjeux de compétitivité
techniques commerciaux et industriels
je m'aperçois que au fur et à mesure que
je fais des conférences et c'est que
google est évidemment très bien connu
par les utilisateurs dans son
fonctionnement je vais prendre que
quelques minutes 5 exactement pour
expliquer le notre entreprise et son
fonctionnement vous savez que nous
sommes une toute jeune entreprise encore
une fois cette révolution digitale
c'était aussi la révolution de la
vitesse nous sommes nés en 98 en
californie issue créé par deux étudiants
de stanford il suffit d'un projet
brevets de propriété de l'université de
stanford et la mission de cette
entreprise est de proposer aux
internautes via son moteur de recherche
des résultats les plus pertinents les
plus précis possibles
cette entreprise californienne a
vocation à construire des produits et
des plateformes globales adressant des
milliards d'internautes dans le monde et
à chercher à élaborer un dispositif
industriel le plus efficient possible
il ya eu une révolution technologique
c'est le moteur de recherche de google
j'y reviendrai rapidement au travers de
cette ce petit clin d'oeil sur les
requêtes concernant les chambres d'hôtes
à marquis il ya une révolution également
dans le modèle économique puisque vous
savez que nous avons changé le modèle
publicitaire imaginé auparavant que vous
êtes un commerçant vous un grand
distributeur vous acheter de la
publicité à la radio dans la presse
quotidienne régionale
cette publicité vous la payer a priori
quel que soit l'impact de la publicité
le modèle publicitaire de google celle
inverse vous ne payez co clic
c'est-à-dire à partir du moment où un
prospect est rentré dans votre magasin
donc imaginer le même distributeur qui
paye ses spots à la radio ses spots en
affichage à partir du moment uniquement
ou le prospect est rentré dans son
magasin c'est l'autre révolution du
modèle google
c'est ce que nous avons lui illustré
rapidement donc il ya plusieurs dizaines
2 millions de requêtes des milliards
dans le monde tous les jours en france
ne reprit cette requête chambres d'hôtes
marquis monsieur le rapporteur
vous voyez s'afficher au dessus où vous
voyez un peu moins bien deux ou trois
emplacements privilégiés avec des liens
en verre sur les sites web de deux
personnes qui possèdent des chambres des
chambres d'hôtes la pratique sens lancar
de riz avec des numéros de téléphone et
vous avez à droite
onze emplacements de même nature c'est
comme dans un magasin physique les trois
emplacements qui sont au dessus
pensez un peu aux allées au bond hall en
allée centrale c'est vraiment
l'emplacement premium privilégié et à
droite c'est un peu les têtes de
gondoles et nous vendons donc ce que
nous appelons des liens sponsorisés
c'est à dire la possibilité pour des
annonceurs via leur site web de répondre
à la question je cherche une chambre
d'hôte à marquer c'est une révolution
considérable puisque c'est un paiement
au clic est pas a priori on maîtrise
totalement le budget vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà dès cet après-midi créer une
campagne pour un euro il vous suffit
d'une tante carte bancaire vous inscrire
en ligne et il n'y a aucune condition de
sortie c'est à dire que si vous avez un
euro à investir vous avez 6 et 1 euro
vous vous sortez à tout moment j'insiste
sur ce point parce que et c'est ce qui
m'a surpris en rejoignant le groupe
google il ya un an et ni venant de deux
grands groupes industriels français
c'est que nous traitons en grande partie
les relations avec des pme avec des
artisans avec des commerçants qui
découvre avec ce modèle un modèle de
coûts publicitaires variable c'est à
dire je ne paie que quand je gagne
puisque je connais la marche que je fais
sur une chambre d'hôte donc si j'ai sans
clic et que je vends une chambre pour
cent clic je sais que je fais 22 euros
par exemple de marc et je peux donc
définir mon budget c'est un mode c'est
aussi la deuxième révolution du modèle
google pour servir ce modèle global
c'est-à-dire des produits à l'usure jean
gratuite le moteur de recherche gmail
google earth google maps l'ensemble de
nos de nos produits gratuits pour tous
les utilisateurs nous faisons financer
ces produits par la publicité selon le
modèle que je viens de vous décrire
donc le schéma industriel de google ce
sont des produits globaux conçu par des
ingénieurs essentiellement en californie
pensé pour l'ensemble des internautes un
dispositif industriel pour servir les
annonceurs ce dispositif à son centre de
gravité à dublin
nous avons à dublin peu plus de 2000
collaborateurs qui servent des
annonceurs allant de la russie à
l'afrique du sud
donc je suis sur ce point puisque
l'implantation industrielle à dublin
correspond à les critères évidemment
technique des plateformes de conches et
rhj à rendre les plus efficiente
possible
l'attractivité du pays nous avons des
jeunes diplômés d'écoles de commerce ou
d'université les meilleurs d'europe qui
traite en ligne des annonceurs et la
possibilité de servir à l'échelle ces
annonces parce que cette révolution est
très technique parce que somme nos
produits sont assez compliqué dans
certains pays les principaux pays grands
pays c'est une quarantaine de pays pour
google nous avons des équipes locales
qui sont des équipes de support et ce
sont ces équipes locales que je dirige
de supports pédagogiques didactiques et
de support également marketing vous avez
pu voir par exemple la publicité à la
télévision la publicité pour notre
produit chrome ses équipes locales de
support traite en france à peu près 500
groupes nous sommes organisés en neuf
secteurs industriels
ce sont des équipes qui sont chargés
d'évangéliser d'accompagner les grands
groupes industriels de l'automobile de
la finance des télécoms de la grande
distribution de la grande consommation
donc je souhaitais en quelques minutes
vous décrire ce ce schéma industriel est
évidemment un volet fiscal à notre
implantation à dublin en irlande qui
n'est qu'un des éléments du choix du
dispositif industriel de google le
l'organisation que je viens de décrire
jean-marc elle répond à un enjeu de
concurrence qui est très fort sur sur
internet et de compétitivité entre les
différents pays sur internet on a
coutume de dire que la concurrence est
un clic pour changer de site
c'est un flic donc en environnement très
très ouvert où facebook microsoft amazon
apple sont autant de concurrents
potentiels sur les sur les différentes
activités de google est il donc dans ce
contexte
google se doit d'être d'être vigilant en
termes de concurrence dans tous les
domaines y compris y compris fiscaux et
dans le domaine dans le domaine fiscal
google respecte naturellement les règles
françaises et européennes mais veillent
tout aussi naturellement à être
compétitif par rapport à ses concurrents
afin de dégager les mêmes ressources
d'investissement dans la r&d dans
l'innovation pour proposer des nouveaux
produits et de nouvelles applications au
fil du temps on consacre une part
importante
le groupe consacre une part importante
de ses ressources à la à la r&d à la
recherche et développement en 2011
c'était 5 milliards de dollars au plan
mondial
ce qui est intéressant c'est que il ya
une part significative de cet
investissement qui qui a été réalisé en
france et qui réalisait en france en
particulier depuis depuis deux ans un
centre de recherche et développement à
100 d'ingénieurs a été créée à paris un
institut culturel a été basée à paris à
l'institut qui a une vocation mondiale
c'est une équipe d'ingénieurs qui
travaillent sur des projets culturels
un bilan à grâce aux technologies du
numérique de l'internet à promouvoir et
valoriser le patrimoine culturel
français européen et mondial s'est
il a une vocation modèle depuis paris
c'est par exemple une des réalisations
séparables le art project c'est un
projet qui vise à afin qui permet aux
internautes de visiter à distance les
musées les plus prestigieux dans le
monde et qui permet aux internautes de
visualiser leurs oeuvres à distance en
france c'est par exemple le château de
versailles le musée d'orsay le musée du
quai branly le château de fontainebleau
ou le château de chantilly qui
bénéficient déjà de
ce projet dans le domaine de la
recherche universitaire il ya également
un investissement important de la part
de google en 2011
un partenariat a été noué avec le cnrs
avec cinq laboratoires du cnrs à travers
la france dans le domaine de
l'optimisation mathématiques et puis
dans des domaines non scientifique on a
par exemple créé récemment avec hec une
chaire universitaire dédié aux métiers
de l'internet
et enfin troisième volet
d'investissements c'est dans le domaine
du soutien aux startups et et aux
entrepreneurs
google a contribué au lancement du
premier accélérateur de start up
internet en france située à paris qui
est baptisé l'eau qui s'est baptisé le
camping porté par l'association silicon
sentier
c'est un programme de camps de coaching
ou des promotions entrepreneurs de
l'internet passe six mois pour
développer accélérer leurs projets alors
ce qui est important de souligner c'est
que ces investissements google
interviennent à un moment clé du
développement du secteur internet
français de l'économie numérique
française en 2011 le cabinet mckinsey a
publié une impact une étude d'impact sur
l'impact de l'internet sur l'économie
française il a estimé que qu'en 2009
internet représentait 3 2% du pib et que
seraient quinze dernières années
c'est un secteur qui a créé en emplois
nets
sept cent mille emplois en gants net y
compris les réallocations d'emplois mais
surtout l'étude souligne que la france
était un tournant dans la mesure où où
elle estime que d'ici 2015
internet va passer à 5 5% du pib qui est
créé quatre cent cinquante mille emplois
supplémentaires nets toujours au total
google mais n'est pas né pas né en
france et on ne peut que le regretter
mais mais l'entreprise
c'est ce que j'ai voulu vous montrer
contribuer significativement à l'essor
d'un écosystème numérique français qui
est créateur de valeur nette pour
l'ensemble de l'économie
en termes de croissance et d'emploi dans
d'autres pays
cet apport de l'internet à l'économie
est plus important par exemple au
royaume uni ces 7 % du pib
un versus la france 3,2 pour cent ça
montre là les perspectives en termes de
croissance et d'emploi qui a que que
recèle ce secteur internet et ça milite
en faveur d'une politique du numérique
volontariste de ce point de vue
l'ouverture et la transversalité de des
travaux de votre commission et sont très
importants à l'occasion de cette mission
vous voyez on a souhaité mettre l'accent
sur l'impact de l'internet sur
l'économie française et ainsi partager
avec vous la même conviction que nous
avions partagé lorsqu une taxe sur la
publicité sur internet avait été votée
fin 2010 à savoir qu' il serait
injustifié et néfaste de de singulariser
le secteur internet mais fast parce que
ça risquerait d'impacter la
compétitivité et l'attractivité de la
france pour les entrepreneurs et les
investissements d'entreprises telles que
google est injustifiée parce que les
questions de fiscalité ne sont
certainement pas spécifique au secteur
de l'internet
voilà je vous remercie puis on sera pas
disponible pour nos questions merci
beaucoup
donc je passe la parole je m'accrochais
de merci monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs membres de cette commission
enquête je vous remercie à mon tour de
de bien vouloir entendre notre société
j'espère vous apporter les éclairages
que vous souhaitez en tout cas dans le
cadre de votre mission et je serai d
après ce propos introductif à votre
entière disposition pour répondre à
toutes les questions dans la mesure
effectivement mais aussi de mes
compétences sur sur ces sujets là
rapidement vous verrez ensemble
peut-être de similitudes entre nos
propos je voudrais juste rappeler que
nous sommes en france depuis bientôt
trente ans c'est bientôt en 83 notre
société a été créée qui les 75 pour
microsoft au niveau mondial et depuis
cette époque là nous sommes engagés à
travailler au renforcement de
l'industrie logicielle française et à
son écosystème
puisque notre premier métier notre
métier d'origine c'est celui d'être
éditeur de logiciels ce qui couvre à la
fois les logiciels du monde grand public
les logiciels le professionnel le jeu
vidéo qui est aussi du logiciel de
loisirs mais aussi de l'activité
internet qui passe par de l'algorithme
qui à certains égards est également du
logiciel ce que je voudrais dire dans un
premier temps sais c'est que cette
présence en france traduit un ancrage
pour une démarche partenariale de long
terme et j'insisterai sur cette
dimension de long terme qui explique et
permet de comprendre la l'organisation
juridique et fiscale à travers laquelle
nous sommes présents dans notre pays
quelques chiffres qui sont semble-t-il
assez éclairant microsoft en france
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 1700
collaborateurs qui sont à la fois dans
microsoft france
l'entité agents commissionnés qui
et est présent sur le territoire
microsoft france r&d que nous avons
créée en 2009 musiwave qui est une
entreprise pme françaises que nous avons
acquis et qui a été intégré dans le
groupe microsoft est également le siège
international de microsoft fonctions de
support à cet instant l'ensemble étant
situé dans le grand paris a ici les
minots pour être plus précis microsoft
et cela vient d'être dit c'est très
important dans le domaine du numérique
est une entreprise qui fonctionne avec
un écosystème
une étude est gay c'est qui est un
institut indépendant qui est
régulièrement produite montre que
l'écosystème microsoft génère environ 75
mille emplois indirects
de quoi s'agit-il s'agit d'intégrateur
de sociétés de services de revendeurs
mais également des éditeurs de logiciels
qui développe des solutions à partir de
nos plateformes technologiques
c'est un élément tout à fait important
ça représente à peu près onze mille 500
partenaires qui sont dans cet écosystème
un autre élément tout à fait essentiel
gentiment jean marc tassetto peut-être
que nous n'avons pas fait la recherche
sur le même moteur de recherche mais
s'agissant de l'aide aux start up il se
trouve que depuis 2005 nous avons créé
un mécanisme d' aide et soutien aux
start-up donc depuis bien longtemps
maintenant et ce mécanisme qui s'appelle
bizpark gelé pour hollande ici c'est
l'étincelle du business bizspark a
permis d'aider 1090 start up qui ont
créé peu ou prou 7000 emplois directs
qui vont de la toute petite start up à
la pme qui a 200 250
le salarié ces dégâts je veux donner
quelques exemples parce que ce sont des
exemples tangibles
criteo ça fait partie des grandes start
up qui est un leader mondial de
méthodologie de publicité sur internet
kobojo qui était fondée en 2008 et qui
était leader européen du jeu social
online commerce gaye qui était désolé un
politique spécialiste du e-commerce en
open source et dans la solution est
utilisée par plus de dix mille sites
dans le monde où israël soft qui est
créateur de l'application angie et qui a
été développé avec leur attaque à lille
avec des partenaires historiques de
microsoft quelques exemples on pourrait
multiplier psion à 1090 c'est ces
startups et ses pme révèle quelque chose
de tout à fait essentiel qui vient
d'être indiqué c'est que l'écosystème
français du numérique est très fort et
tout l'enjeu sur lequel nous sommes
engagés
c'est effectivement de faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent se développer et de
façon durable de façon pérenne et ça
commence très tôt j'ai cité kobojo
kobojo est un excellent exemple parce
que kobojo avant même d'être dans le
programme bizspark était dans un autre
programme que nous avons monté qui
s'appelle imagine cup qui est une
compétition mondiale des écoles et ces
écoles développe des solutions tourné
vers la résolution de problèmes de
société cette année cap street qui est
porté par cinq étoiles de cinq écoles de
la région toulousaine développe un
logiciel pour les personnes handicapées
pour qu'elle puisse trouver les
meilleurs parcours dans la ville en
fonction de leur handicap qu'elles
puissent visiter les sites certains
musées en ayant les possibilités
d'accessibilité des meilleurs et ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que depuis la
création de imagine cup ces compétitions
mondiales c'est plus de cent mille
étudiants par an en 2003 eh bien la
france
les écoles françaises sont celles qui
ont reçu le plus de médailles 23
médailles dont 9 d'or donc ce sont les
jeunes français qui sont en tête de la
compétition devant les chinois on pense
souvent voilà c'est ailleurs que se
passe le développement logiciel bien non
ce sont des jeunes français qui gagne à
chaque fois et kobojo qui mène dans une
start-up une pme est né dans imagine cup
un autre exemple tout à fait essentiel
c'est le partenariat qu'on a créé en
2005 avec l'inria que vous connaissez
bien qui est un établissement public de
recherche fondamentale
ce partenariat sur le plateau de saclay
et est un partenariat qui est dédié à
quatre enjeux clés de l'industrie
numérique et au progrès scientifique
sécurité fiabilité des logiciels
intelligence artificielle visualisation
des données et traitement d'imagés de
vidéos ainsi que le fameux cloud
computing l'informatique en nuage
c'est un laboratoire de recherche
fondamentale qui comporte 50 chercheurs
ce qui est tout à fait intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un des laboratoires
les plus réputés dans le monde par
rapport à ces sujets il publie dans
toutes les grandes revues et dans tous
les grands colloques
ce qui est également important et
intéressant nous aurons peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler
c'est que dans le cadre de ce
partenariat les résultats des travaux de
recherche sont sous licence ouverte
autrement dit tous les résultats qui
peuvent être faits dans le cadre de ces
travaux sont sous une licence cécile b
qui a été conçu par trois établissements
publics français
le cnrs l'inria une cea et cela
conduirait tout simplement est ce que si
les résultats peuvent être exploitées
l'inria peut tout à fait le faire peut
tout à fait le faire en créant pourquoi
pas une start up et il aura la
possibilité d'utiliser la licence
ouverte dont il s'agit
les résultats ne sont pas la propriété
exclusive de microsoft en aucune façon
et donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des actifs
qui via ce laboratoire vont pouvoir
demeurer en france et participer
peut-être de certains développements via
l'inria c'est un partenariat que nous
avons renouvelé en 2009 pour 4 ans et je
vous dis les choses très simplement
depuis nous versions depuis la création
1 million 250 mille euros par an dans ce
laboratoire commun dont les résultats
encore une fois sont ouverts dernier
exemple que par lequel je voudrais
terminer ce premier tour d'horizon des
organisations ces musiques web c'est une
pme françaises qui travaillaient dans la
mobilité technologique et cette pme de
170 personnes a été acquise par
microsoft et chose intéressante avant
que nous l'accueillons elle bénéficie du
crédit impôt recherche
cela nous a incités à la conserver en
france à la localiser en france et à
continuer à la développer
cela étant je dois dire que depuis son
intégration nous n'avons pas redemander
de dossiers de ces hier
c'est intéressant parce que ça a été un
élément déterminant dans le fait que
cette entreprise a pu se créer se
développer cela a attiré notre regard
nous avons concentré depuis notre effort
sur la réussite dans son intégration et
depuis nous continuons à recruter les
agr de très haut niveau et cette
structure au sein de microsoft
corporation
mais localisés en france développe pour
le monde entier des partie conséquente
de notre plateforme de divertissement
dernier point puisque j'évoque et le le
crédit impôt recherche
l'inria si l'on se réfère à l'article 49
ces petits f-16 3 du code général des
impôts
s'agissant de recherche fondamentale à
des projets qui seraient éligibles au
seiller depuis 2005 je vous disais que
nous avons abonder ce laboratoire commun
nous n'avons présenté qu'un dossier pour
l'instant en terme de ces hier c'est en
2011 pour un montant qui pourrait si le
dossier était avalisée représenter cent
cinquante cinq cent quarante mille euros
mais c'est le premier de ce que nous
représentons pour un versement d'un
million 250 mille euros par an et encore
une fois
qu'est-ce qui a commandé c'est pas des
raisons fiscales ou d'optimisation du cg
juste que ce sont les résultats
scientifiques d'un comité scientifique
puisque dans ce laboratoire commun il ya
des chercheurs l'inria et les chercheurs
de microsoft research cambridge et
microsoft france r&d qui y siègent
voilà quelques exemples qui permet
d'ailleurs au détour de dire que le
crédit impôt recherche est un véritable
outil d'attractivité pour la france à
condition qu'il soit utilisé à bon
escient et pour des réalisations
véritable voilà sur ces éléments là je
terminerai par expliqué qu' évidemment
l'organisation juridique et fiscale
tient compte de cette réalité nous
sommes effectivement microsoft france
pour la partie de promotion des ventes
une sas créée depuis 1983
à cet égard effectivement nous sommes en
relation avec miaule qui est nôtre
microsoft island opérations limited qui
est l'acteur de centralisation des
opérations en irlande nous sommes sont
agents commissionnés en france son agent
commercial puisque évidemment nous
réalisons des opérations de promotion
des ventes des opérations d'information
ces nouveaux produits et d'offres auprès
des grossistes et des partenaires
ou encore d'activités effectivement de
consulting de ss2i ou de maintenance
la réalité c'est que microsoft à reims
et l'acteur qui centralise pour toute
l'europe
les activités de production et microsoft
irlande est également copropriétaire des
droits de propriété intellectuelle de
développement sur les logiciels pour le
dire autrement
d'un point de vue du cadre juridique et
fiscal les risques afférents aux marchés
les risques de développement ses
meilleurs qui les prend je donnerai un
simple exemple pour le comprendre même 2
dont l'un fera sans doute discussions
par la suite le premier c'est la xbox
vous savez on est dans les consoles de
jeux lorsqu'en 2001 microsoft
corporation prend une décision
stratégique d'entrée sur ce secteur ce
segment en disant peut-être que d'ici
quelques années dans le salon de chaque
particulier la console de jeu jouent un
rôle peut-être deux ordinateurs
domestiques et bien il faut se lancer
sur ce marché qui était occupé par sony
nintendo donc pendant des années on a
développé sur ce terrain là à perte
c'était une activité non profitable et
pour autant microsoft france agents
commissionnés ne supportant aucun risque
de marché à au titre de la commission
payer des impôts sur une activité qui
était déficitaire le risque de marché le
risque de développement était pris par
la corporation et parmi eux microsoft
france n'étant que l'agent
commissionnaires cet instant on pourrait
prendre évidemment le même exemple avec
notre activité online
jean marc tassetto gentiment nous citer
parmi les moteurs de recherche je dois
avouer que je sais pas s'il fera plaisir
mais que nous n'avons qu'entre 2 et 3%
de part de marché à cet égard nous
sommes bien bien petit à côté d'un
acteur dominant sur ce marché il n'en
demeure pas moins que cette activité et
ses publics est déficitaire au niveau
mondial nous permet cependant du fait du
statut des agents commissionnés de payer
des impôts en france alors même qu'elle
est non profitables et est déficitaire
c'est un mécanisme qui parce que nous ne
prenons pas le risque microsoft france
de risques de marché de dos risque de
développement nous permet cependant
d'assumer et d'assurer un minimum de
rentrées fiscales et pour le dire là
encore librement
nous avons fait l'objet depuis je crois
1996 de contrôles fiscaux par
l'administration
française d'autres dans le monde toutes
ont validé le prix de transfert que nous
avons mis en place la mission française
continue mais la couenne distractif
d'appel de paris de versailles pardon le
16 10 février 2012 à valider notre
méthode de calcul
cela étant voilà nous avons un dialogue
ouvert avec avec l'administration
fiscale française sur ce terrain là pour
dire les choses il est tellement ouvert
que nous sommes un peu comme héloïse
éclair de jean jacques rousseau dont les
coeurs et qui est transparent l'une à
l'autre il n'ya plus de secret ni pour
eux ni pour nous et nous avons ce
dialogue qui encore une fois est fondé
sur une réalité de marché une réalité
organisé qui est reflète et c'est tout à
fait essentiel l'importance que nous
accordons à l'écosystème français tout
en ayant un cadre juridique et fiscal
qui corresponde à une réalité
d'organisation de l'entreprise au niveau
mondial en europe et en france
merci très bien je vous remercie je
passe la parole à notre rang porter oui
monsieur mousse et je vais commencer par
ce avec quoi vous avez terminé mais je
crois savoir que l'entreprise a remporté
un procès récemment qui l'opposait à
l'administration fiscale française
pouvez vous nous indiquer de quelle
litige il s'agissait exactement et jc
tout simplement de la méthode de calcul
du prix de transfert et la cua une
sortie d'à peine confirmant le timide
illustratif de paris a confirmé que la
méthode de calcul était la bonne époque
et elle a gelé contentieux ses
administrations fiscales qui contestait
la méthode de calcul d'accord sur un
plan plus général
est ce que vous pourriez l'un et l'autre
présenter votre implantation à l'échelle
internationale et tous les pays ou
territoires dans lesquels il est
implanté
les activités vous y mener le nombre de
salariés que ça induit le chiffre
d'affaires un peu l'état des lieux
de chacun de vos groupes s'il vous plaît
pour démarrer très bien pour pour
démarrer google
le chiffre d'affaires google vous
souhaitez très bien en fait donc le
chiffre d'affaires de 2 de google global
quand on est un peu moins de 40
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires pour 33 mille collaborateurs
dont une très forte proportion
d'ingénieures basée en californie façon
dominante avec quelques implantations en
particulier en europe de centres de
recherche et développement nous avons
une grosse implantation à zurich avec à
peu près 1000 ingénieurs et quelques uns
pop implantation significative notamment
londres et paris qui devient comme
olivier l'a souligné un centre de
recherche et de développement qui nous
permet de fixer des ingénieurs français
puisqu'il ya monsieur l'a rappelé il ya
quand même une filière ingénieur
français brillante il ya il ya une
french connection chez google en matière
de d'ingénieurs donc on arrive à en
fixer une bonne partie à paris et nous
attirons également à paris des
ingénieurs étrangers qui travaillent
encore une fois sur des sujets globaux
notre opérating système android chrome
de la plateforme youtube
l'amélioration de la situation des
données qui sont des sujets qui réclame
des compétences mathématiques de très
haut niveau
l'implantation plus spécifiquement par
pays donc par exception google ad épique
à des équipes support dans les pays
ce n'est pas le modèle dominant
puisqu'il ya moins de pays avec des keys
équipes support qu'il ya deux pays qui
travaillent
globalement avec google c'est le cas
pour les grands pays d'europe de l'ouest
et d'europe continentale jusqu'à la
russie
nous avons en france pour la au sein de
la sarl google qui agit donc en support
de l'activité commerciale de google
ireland un peu plus de 150
collaborateurs et nous avons à paris un
peu plus de 400 collaborateurs google
dont une partie liée à l'institut
culturel qui devient d'ailleurs un
institut mondial parce qu'on a cité des
musées français mais on vient de finir
nos ingénieurs viennent de finir la
digitalisation des archives de nelson
mandela et nous travaillons sur des
grands projets mondiaux donc c'est aussi
une chance d'avoir à paris c'est le seul
endroit au monde où google à un institut
culturel à dublin je voulais dis donc à
paris nous couvrons à peu près un
support nous intervenons support d'à peu
près 500 groupes industriels en sachant
que dublin traite pour la france à peu
près 60 mille annonceurs des plus
importants les grands groupes
industriels que j'ai cités au plus petit
blogueur qui achètent pour quelques
euros de la visibilité sur sur internet
tant que le modèle d'une et donc à
dublin
c'est une implantation d'un peu plus de
l'excusé moi 2000 collaborateurs de
toutes nationalités
d'ailleurs je me permets de si vous en
avez l'occasion de venir visiter comme
l'ont fait certains sénateurs de notre
plateforme de dublin pour bien
comprendre le schéma industriel
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur vous êtes évidemment les
bienvenus dans ce souci d'information et
de et de transparence il y à un accord
entre la srm google france signé en 2004
et google ireland qui couvre l'activité
de supports de marketing de pédagogie
d'évangélisation du marché français et
pourquoi ce choix de l'irlande dans
votre l'importation du siège
quelles étaient les motivations
initiales de ce choix les choix
d'implantation de plateformes sont
souvent comme vous le savez le multi
critères la première c'est
l'environnement un gouvernement stable
c'est pas discriminant pour ce qui
concerne irlande en fait c'est un des
critères un environnement économique est
un écosystème important je dois dire que
la présence de grands groupes comme
microsoft met de grands groupes
bancaires pharmaceutique télécom dans
cet écosystème irlandais a participé du
caractère rassurant de l'implantation
d'une plate forme technique
technologique l'aptitude a attiré 2000
collaborateurs qui sont des
collaborateurs d'une moyenne d'âge de 28
30 ans qui ont envie de qui sont en âge
de fonder des familles d'avoir des
enfants qui fait lien l'ensemble est
évidemment la dimension fait de ce qu'un
des nationalités les collaborateurs ils
viennent au quick ouvre encore une fois
de la russie à l'afrique du sud donc
quand vous êtes sur des plateaux qui
prête en ligne les annonceurs
vous avez laissé très très spectaculaire
espèce de tour de babel vous ayez
drapeau français polonais portugais
irlandais roumain africain sud-africain
français j'ai cité français bien entendu
pour dire que les français ne représente
qu'une partie de ces 2000 collaborateurs
donc c'est un choix dans lequel il ya
évidemment eu une dimension fiscale en
particulier lié à lies puisque notre
activité dominé de façon dominante une
activité d'entreprise à entreprise donc
nous n'étions pas jusqu'à présent
concernés par les sujets de tva mais
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris peut-être un
temps un peu long pour décrire le schéma
industriel c'est encore une fois
l'implantation à dublin correspondent à
des critères multi multi choix dans la
fiscalité
sur les mêmes en espérant que je vais
avoir tous les chiffres en tête donc
microsoft au niveau mondial ces 60
milliards de dollars chiffre d'affaires
il ya plus de 90 mille salariés
36000 sont des développeurs ce n'est pas
un différent parce que c'est un modèle
industriel qui est fondée sur
l'innovation la recherche développement
15% du chiffre d'affaires de
l'entreprise niveau mondial est consacré
à la r&d et il ya trois ans de ça pour
le dernier classement je le crois je
veux pas dire une bêtise que nous étions
tous secteurs confondus le premier
groupe en termes de dépenses de r&d au
niveau mondial
après quoi il ya une organisation par
région que j'évoquais rapidement dans
mon intervention liminaire avec trois
pôles de centralisation pour la
production et la contractualisation et
il y à singapour pour l'asie pacifique
il ya des usa pour les usa l'amérique du
sud et le canada est violent
microsoft irlande opérations limited
pour la zone i et millet et donc à cet
égard microsoft france
comme les autres filiales de la zone y
aimiez sont des agents commissionnés 2
demi heure avec le même mécanisme qui
s'applique et qui a été validé dans tout
dans tous les pays effectivement à cet
instant nos clients français
ce qu'on contracte avec miaule il n'y en
a noté le chiffrement devenir du couple
cité pas sur 29 milles il y en avait en
2009 29 1713 voilà qui contractaient
avec avec miaule microsoft france
n'ayant à cet instant qu'une activité en
tant qu'agent commissionné de promotion
de présentation des offres de
maintenance de support technique
donc cette activité qui est défini dans
le cas de notre relation avec miaule
étant entendu encore une fois que pour
les activités de r&d que j'ai pu citer
il ya une structure ad-hoc qui est écrit
que s'appelle microsoft france r&d pour
permettre de développer les
investissements que que l'on a évoqué
il a été donné aucune indication dans
des articles de presse fréquent que
google revient à vous avez une entité
aux bermudes
si vous confirmez quelle est l'activité
de cette entité
quelles sont les motivations qui les ce
soit d'implantation également sur les
bermudes
concernant google
c'est difficile pour nous de confirmer
ou d'infirmer dans l'organisation qui a
été décrite par jean-marc on est
principe on est en contact avec soin
google ireland soit la maison mère aux
états unis en californie dans la silicon
valley pour tout ce qui est
développement de produits conception de
nouveaux produits
question suivante concernant la
fiscalité du commerce électronique qui
est revenu souvent à la commission
puisque c'est une nouveauté de des
échanges commerciaux vent lui et l'ont
qui a des incidences mais sur sur la
fiscalité
quelle est votre analyse du processus de
réforme de la tva ainsi que de
l'imposition des bénéfices au niveau
européen et international
et quelles incidences concrètes
anticipez vous pour votre entreprise et
votre secteur d'activité
je répondrai en temps de parole nous
restons vigilants parce que quand
microsoft à 2% de part de marché les
choses vont tellement vite
le épreuve premier quelques quelques
éléments le e-commerce en france c'est
même si la fevad a publié les chiffres
récents en disant que le e-commerce
avait progressé de + 27% en est quand
même qu'à 40 milliards d'euros à
comparer à 100 milliards d'euros en
allemagne et 100 milliards d'euros au
royaume-uni donc à nos enjeux à nous en
particulier les équipes support en
français comment peut-on faire pour que
cet écosystème des e-marchands soit
e-marchands pur je pense à ce partout
qui a créé une soixantaine d'emplois
grenoble je pense à sarenza qui est une
plate forme logistique à beauvais se
développe encore plus rapidement l'enjeu
est lié au développement rattrapage de
la situation du e-commerce en france par
rapport aux pays du nord de l'europe qui
en termes d'impact du digital l économie
en perte du e-commerce qu'on montre un
peu la voie et le chemin si je le dis
positivement on a tout un tas de bonnes
nouvelles devant nous au regard du
e-commerce et je pense à l'impact
économique je pense à une partie des 400
450 mille emplois nets a créé et je
pense à la à la tva collectée par les
acteurs du e-commerce donc un des sujets
pour nous c'est comment on libère et
comment le cadre fiscal et juridique
libère cette cette énergie et libère cet
enjeu une incidence sur les emplois on
ne parle pas uniquement là d' emplois
d'ingénieurs de techniciens de de haut
niveau on parle également d' emploi de
manutentionnaire dans des plateformes
logistiques qui met dans des boîtes des
produits qui vont être livrés donc il
est absolument fondamental que le cadre
fiscales et juridiques libère ses
énergies au service de la coupe de la
croissance oui rapidement sur un point
s'agissant de deux du e-commerce gérer
un peu plus loin parce que je pense
qu'il ya une dimension tout à fait
essentiel qui ne doit pas être négligée
et qui est vraiment importante pour le
développement de l'économie numérique en
france
mais au delà de l'économie tout court
c'est développement du cloud computing
l'informatique en nuage fois c'est tout
à fait essentiel parce que c'est une
opportunité pour beaucoup d'entreprises
soit du numérique d'accéder à la
puissance de calcul pour se développer
soit pour des entreprises qui ne sont
pas du tout dans ce secteur-là d'accéder
à des marchés y compris à
l'international à des coûts beaucoup
moins élevées qu'elles ne le pourrait
s'il devait investir dans des serveurs
dans des infrastructures qu'elles
n'auront pas besoin d'aller acheter pour
installer chez elle mais qu'elles
pourront utiliser via les offres
d'ensemble de prestataires et cette
dimension là est tout à fait essentiel
parce que c'est un accélérateur de
croissance et un accélérateur de
création d'emplois et ça c'est un
élément essentiel qu'il ne faut surtout
pas pénaliser s'il ya une réflexion à
cet égard je pense que la réflexion sur
la passe il faut le dire ainsi mais la
fiscalité du numérique en général doit
prendre en compte toutes ses dimensions
là ça ne se limite pas au e-commerce qui
est une partie importante mais au delà
du commerce
il ya toute cette possibilité de créer
des plateformes technologiques à partir
desquels on peut soit développé des
start up ou c'est le modèle que
j'évoquais bizpark depuis 2005 soit tout
simplement de permettre à des pme
françaises qui sont général sous-équipés
en matière d'accès au net et au
développement de leur plateforme
technologique d'accéder à quelque chose
qu'il a permis de se développer sur le
marché international et cette dimension
là doit être doit être prise en compte
pour le reste c'est cette qui sont qu
une question légitime qui est posée par
le plusieurs parlementaires depuis un
moment j'ai dire la réponse revient au
parlement et au gouvernement en la
matière et s'il ya des des travaux
d'harmoniser officielle européenne
ils se feront évidemment nous nous
rentrerons dans ce cadre là sans
difficulté s'agissant de microsoft
encore une fois l'essentiel de notre
activité c'est de la production via
l'édition de logiciels et même avec une
activité déficitaire nous nous payons
des impôts sur cette partie là de notre
activité
ce repos en cas d'évolution de la
fiscalité dans les différents pays où il
est implanté qui pourrait peut-être se
traduire par un alourdissement de la
charge fiscale
on évoque parfois le cas de l'irlande
qui connaît situation économique très
difficile et dont on ne sait où ça va
atterrir quelque part est ce que ça
pourrait entraîner chez vous une
réorganisation territoriale complète au
sein de vos deux groupes
dans la mesure où nos choix sont dictés
par une recherche permanente de
compétitivité il est évident que les
décisions prises et dans la mesure où
ces sujets de cette révolution digitale
va extrêmement vite
il est évident que si les dispositifs
change
il est dans notre responsabilité mois un
niveau local mais le plus sérieusement
google inc d'adapter ses explosifs
industriels aux opportunités
industrielles technique commercial et
fiscal ce qui met permet vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le rapporteur de
considérer que ces sujets là sont des
sujets d'harmonisation fiscale
européenne etc al'inverse dans notre
préoccupation locale
le fait de ne pas dégrader la
compétitivité fiscale de la france à
l'aune de ces enjeux d'implantation nous
semble extrêmement important
on aurait pu rêver d'avoir les de la
plateforme des 2000 collaborateurs du
blinois en france dans les critères que
j'ai cités il ya un certain nombre de
critères qui correspondait parfaitement
à l'écosystème français
malheureusement passe pas le pas le
critère fiscale concernant le crédit
d'impôt recherche qui a été évoqué quel
montant cela a représenté pour vos deux
groupes
s'il vous plaît vous le savez
aujourd'hui j'ai rien la première
demande a été faite pour l'année 2011
saisissant du laboratoire de recherche
fondamentale enfin par microsoft france
r&d concernant les travaux de recherche
au sein du laboratoire commun mais
jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu de
versement il a un dossier qui est en
cours mais il n'y a pas eu de de
bénéfices tirés mais à cet égard et je
rebondis sur ce que vient de dire
monsieur tassetto crois que c'est tout à
fait essentiel parce que je prenais un
exemple de musiwave je prends l'exemple
des investissements qu'on attire chaque
année sur ce laboratoire commun de
microsoft corporation
le crédit impôt recherche a vraiment
joué un rôle
c'est un mécanisme qui est ancien et
depuis 1983 donc pas il est pas né
d'hier il a connu des évolutions
il est évident qu'il doit fait qu'on
doit en faire un usage à bon escient et
que ça ne doit pas servir à de
l'optimisation indue mais bien utilisé
c'est un facteur à la fois pour des pme
j'ai donné l'exemple de musiwave le
secret de se développer et pour des
investisseurs internationaux ou des
grands groupes d'avoir regard différent
sur le territoire français sans dévoiler
aucun secret particulier lorsqu'elle est
ici on d'investissement qui sont faites
et un tchèque effet un ensemble
d'éléments dimension fiscale à dimension
des services publics la dimension de la
qualité de l'enseignement la dimension
la qualité de l'employabilité des
personnes sur le territoire
parmi tous ces éléments là il est clair
le que le crédit d'impôt recherche
compte
il compte et il permet d'engendrer un
sound d'investissement et je crois
véritablement que la france a et si un
message qui doit passer et j'ai envie de
dire que à cet instant où on a un
message commun qui la france et une est
sans doute une paire du numérique plus
qu'on imagine encore il faudrait juste
que elle ne rate pas le rendez-vous qui
est devant elle elle a une école
mathématiques une école d'ingénieurs
elle a une créativité le numérique le
logiciel que ce soit dans l'algorithme
pour les moteurs de recherche ou dans le
jeu vidéo que ce soit dans le système
d'exploitation dans la mobilité
c'est à la fois de la science et de la
créativité
c'est de la science et de la craie de
vie des développeurs sur des stars comme
comme des stars de football il faut être
capable de les faire naître et quand je
citais imagine cup ce concours qu'on a
qu'on a monté il ya maintenant plus
presque dix ans en 2003 la démonstration
qui est fait c'est que la france est
toujours en quête dans les classements à
cet égard donc il y a beaucoup de rendez
vous il faut pas les rater
il ne faut pas évidemment sombrer dans
les logiques d'optimisation fiscale il
faut pas rater non plus le développement
d'outils incitatifs à la condition
encore une fois qu'ils ne servent pas
d'utilisation indus et à l'université de
valenciennes de ce point de vue est très
en pointe sur tout ce qui a trait au
numérique je sais qu'il ya un pôle très
actif qui produit les choses un bel
exemple à suivre
nous partageons totalement cette cette
conviction et cet enthousiasme pour ce
qui concerne le plan d'investissement
google en france le centre de r&d nous
n'avons pas fait appel au crédit impôt
recherche
à date
oui je reviens avec les petits litiges
qui peuvent survenir à l'administration
fiscale concernant les prix de transfert
donc j'ai bien compris que microsoft
avait un sur sa cause - pas vraiment
d'accord sur ce point l'administration
fiscale mais qu'en est-il de google avez
vous eu des problèmes de lui-même gens
nous sommes nous avons un dialogue
l'administration fiscale il ya eu un
premier contrôle en 2000 dont les
conclusions ont été connues en 2010 qui
a validé notre organisation
il ya un contrôle qui est en cours à ce
jour également
important juste pour préciser que le
juge administratif a validé la méthode
de calcul
et qu'elle a été validée dans tous les
autres pays européens c'était le seul
débat qui restaient en suspens avec la
france
merci brice tant que parlementaire ce
qui nous importe c'est défend les
intérêts de la france en général et de
l'importance que nous pouvons attacher
développement du numérique
je crois que là c'est il faut trouver
toutes les pistes et les bonnes pistes
dans la matière moi j'étais ingénieur en
informatique le groupe paribas en début
de carrière et j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur des outils et à l'époque on avait
d'excellents traitement de texte et mike
rostov s'est imposé au niveau
international avec des mots avec des les
outils qu'ils étaient bien inférieures
aux nôtres
mais la norme américaine a pris les
devants sort des raisons purement virait
des espaces de consommateurs sur la le
génie de nos propres ingénieurs
voilà donc ce n'est pas toujours le
meilleur qui gagne mais en maintenant
des on est dans la dans la boucle
mycroft je voudrais revenir simplement
sûr j'aurais de plusieurs questions mais
la première concerne google quand vous
évoquez monsieur espère vous nous dire
la question de la publicité venue dit ce
serait une erreur de le taxer la
publicité mais monsieur tassetto quand
vous présentez votre vos pages
vous nous dites voilà les publicités et
très vite vous parlez en deux marchés en
asie vous nous indiquez que celles à
deux têtes de gondoles et moi ce que je
vois très clairement c'est une grande un
grand distributeur qui installe sur ce
don son magasin de manière réfléchie
ce qu'il veut mettre sur les têtes de
gondoles et qui fait payer en fait le
producteur et vous êtes en situation de
distribution d'un de différents services
des différents produits vous l'avez dit
vous-même des chambres d'hôtes pour moi
ce sont avant tout c'est un produit la
chambre d'hôtes et pour moi ou c'est pas
de la publicité on est vraiment dans un
acte de distribution et comme tout acte
distribution qui apporte sa dalle à jour
va rajouter comme le faire une agence
qui vont des voyages comme vous pouvez
le faire en vendant tout un tas d'or et
tout un ensemble de produits en les
mettant en scène et en les positionnant
en face à un public très nombreux qui le
plus en plus d'utilisateurs de
l'internet me semble être par définition
non plus un acteur de la publicité mais
avant tout un acteur de la vente et à ce
titre me semble qu'on doit rentrer dans
des règles fiscales
tout à fait
normal tant bien que mal existent pour
n'importe quel magasin ça ma première
remarque est la première question
l'armée s'était cette visite victime de
ma tentative pédagogique
raté donc nous sommes dans l'âme et je
plaisante
elle ne sommes absolument pas notre
statut juridique est très clair nous
avons un statut juridique de plateforme
un distributeur en mode dominant achat
revente est quelqu'un qui achète du
produit et qui marche sur la revente du
produit ce qui n'est absolument pas
notre cas puisque ni sur la vente des
espadrilles sur la vente de nuitées ni
sur la vente d'automobiles
nous ne prétendons à la moindre marge
commerciale nous générons via un clic
une relation entre un industriel qui
peut être lui-même distributeurs
d'ailleurs est quelqu'un qui a posé une
question donc à aucun moment nous ne
sommes et nous nous percevons comme des
distributeurs
on attendait davantage un super un
support publicitaire sur lesquels les
annonceurs choisissent de de s'afficher
donc ils ne payent pas pour s'afficher
enfin je reviens pas sur ce que jean
mach l'exprimer en revanche y paye
lorsqu'un internaute arrive sur le site
et une précision également là j'arrive
plus à projeter le l'écran de tout à
l'heure mais tous les six voilà tous les
sites internet qui sont au milieu ne
paye pas pour figurer au centre c'est ce
qu'on appelle réservant cherche naturel
c'est l'algorithme qui tourne et ces
sites là ces sites internet neuneu ne
paie pas ne paie rien pour pour figurer
ici ce fonds indexés par le moteur de
recherche
je réaffirme ce que je dis en fait vous
êtes un rayonnage et vous fait que vous
faites payer la présence sur ce
rayonnages c'est une forme de
distribution comme une autre et pour
revenir sur moi même j'étais
utilisateurs à titre personnel de de
l'achat justement des premières lignes
sur mon propre nom parce que quand on
attaque quand on cliquait sur mon nom on
tombait sur assure une attaque dont
j'avais fait l'objet par un site débat
de bahamas et est donc je ne pouvais
rien faire contre ce site et pour éviter
que mon nom soit salie par ce site
j'étais obligé d'acheter vos premières
lignes pour pouvoir me protéger ce qui
est complètement paradoxe a donc j'ai
payé de manière et qu'on rit je continue
à payer chaque fois qu'on clique sur mes
propres sites pour me protéger
de fait qu'en première ligne arrivé
cette injure dont je faisais l'objet par
ce site et je suis toujours dans cette
situation là donc je trouve qu'il ya
aussi un problème de moralité
je veux dire que la difficulté à
laquelle on est confronté par l'ensemble
par tous ces outils internet en général
c'est qu'on est transfrontalier on
dépasse complètement le cadre
vraiment le cadre de la moralité dans un
certain nombre de situations
bon moi je crois qu'on a beaucoup de
progrès à faire en la matière et vous
êtes un acteur dominant son marché donc
moi je pense que vous avez là des clés
extrêmement importante à mettre en
oeuvre
on google propose des outils pour pour
adresser ce genre discussions notamment
lorsqu'il ya des des résultats qui
figure qui sont illégaux par exemple
lancé la semaine dernière on a dans le
domaine du de la protection du droit
d'auteur
on a publié le nombre
de liens qui sont retirés chez chaque
mois chaque jour par google à la demande
des ayants droit donc on a les outils
pour permettre d'adresser ce genre de
situation dans le respect des règles du
cadre juridique pour pas évidemment
tomber dans un autre extrait est juste
concernant le le
le message le message sur la fiscalité
notre message n'est pas de dire que leur
activité et chappe à toute fiscalité
c'est à dire que ce serait risqué de
créer une taxe spécifique internet
quelque chose qui singularise internet
mais n'ont pas de dire que on devait
échapper à tout risquer sur la taxe sur
la fiscalité
elles existent ailleurs en europe vous
voulez dire la taxe sur la publicité
bien sûr la police annonce l'accès
internet d'autres parlements eu cette
bonne idée ce serait une première à
notre connaissance ce serait une
première européenne mondiale
si je comprends bien nous sommes en
retard tu vous avez cité des chiffres
tout à l'heure sur l'allemagne
l'angleterre la france c'était 100 100
et 40 fchi du e-commerce ou sur les huit
que même sur le développement du
e-commerce actuellement sont des
chiffres de qu'en 2011-2012 sont les
chiffres 2011 2011
donc en réalité notre pays est en retard
dans ce domaine on peut considérer cela
comme ça où on peut concéder une
évolution
on peut considérer qu'il correspond à un
plan stratégique de développement de
votre part ou c'est un phénomène général
est ce qu'il ya un retard de notre pays
dans ce domaine il ya un retard
comment dire notre pays est bien sûr le
45e parallèle puisque quand on étudie la
situation de l'europe du sud en termes
d'impact d'internet au pib on est sur
l'italie sur l'espagne avant le choc
majeur de la crise sur des chiffres
encore une fois 2011
on est sur 2,2 2,3 pour cent la france a
trois et demi pour cent et le royaume et
il était déjà à 5 et 10% donc on a un
phénomène europe du nord ce qui comme
l'a dit monsieur il ya une espèce de
paradoxe français les individus français
sont extrêmement technophiles trainer en
avance dans leur équipement à l'internet
ce sont les entreprises et les
corporations qui sont par autant la
france est 21e pays sur 27 des pays de
l' ocde en termes d'équipement des pme
en site web et ne pas avoir un site web
au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est avoir un
commerce sans boutique sans vitrine
donc voila se sont tous élèves tous ces
éléments de l'écosystème si on dit on
positive on a un formidable potentiel de
croissance croissance des pme en
particulier des artisans des commerçants
nous avons signé il ya un mois un
partenariat avec la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de marseille provence et
son dynamique président pierre pfister
où nous avons contribué à aider des
artisans des commerçants des pme à venir
en ligne nous avons 12 coach sur le
terrain qui ont fait du porte à porte et
qui ont passé du temps avec des
commerçants pour leur expliquer puisque
leurs voisins commerçants étaient en
ligne e ne l'était pas donc je pense
qu'il ya un très gros enjeu de pédagogie
de l'environnement de l'écosystème
puisque on a devant nous un fort poumon
de développement mais je sais on a un
potentiel mais une créativité mais en
termes de chiffre d'affaires ou de
d'efficacité commerciale et dont fiscale
pour ce qui nous intéresse mais j'arrive
pas à le mettre en oeuvre
je voudrais d'abord dire que le
numérique ne se limite pas au e-commerce
parce que depuis quelques temps le
sentiment c'est que lorsqu'on parle
l'industrie numérique en france de
digital on pense que ça se limite
effectivement à des plates formes de
vente
le e-commerce a un rôle très important à
jouer c'est tout à fait essentiel mais
ce qui me paraît tout aussi important
lorsqu'on parle de filières
industrielles d'excellence c'est de ne
pas oublier ce qui est au coeur de toute
façon des plateformes technologiques
notamment les éditeurs de logiciels
parce que derrière tout ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer il y à du logiciel et de coqs
qui est écrit et il ya du développement
industriel ya deux modèles économiques
à cet instant le modèle ni commerce et
le modèle du moteur de recherche
c'est un modèle fondamentalement tourné
vers la publicité
le modèle de l'édition logicielle c'est
un modèle de r&d d'innovation avec des
risques de marché très important et ce
modèle là la france a des champions
dassault systèmes est un champion
mondial de cet univers cegid
est également un champion on pourrait en
citer un seul membre
encore une fois ce qui me paraît tout à
fait essentiel lorsqu'on parle de
l'écosystème
c'est bien évidemment de ne pas négliger
il ne faut surtout pas pénaliser le
e-commerce français ce serait bien
dommage mais il ne faut pas considérer
que le développement du numérique la
filière d'excellence ne soit que les
commerces
il y à toute l'industrie logicielle je
parlais de rats tech tout à l'heure par
rapport à lille on a pu avoir des
partenaires avec la ville de lyon et que
la ville de paris pour faire monter en
avant ses start up on peut tout à fait
avoir en france le microsoft le facebook
google leleu apple de demain dès lors
qu'on veut bien faire en sorte de
regarder ces filières d'excellence et de
les développer
de ce point de vue si je puis me
permettre on quitte un instant le
terrain la fiscalité mais ce n'est qu'à
moitié éloigné si l'on parle de
politique industrielle de redressement
productif
de quoi s'agit-il à cet instant il
s'agit pas simplement de faire descendre
d'en haut
une vision qui dirait voilà la filière
qui va bien mais d'essayer de faire
monter des projets depuis le terrain
depuis ces pme depuis ces startups y
compris avec les collectivités locales y
compris en partenariat avec les grands
groupes pour essayer de les faire monter
en puissance
c'est ça qui me paraît tout à fait
essentielle tous les bons exemples qu'on
voit et le programme bizspark on a mis
en place depuis 2005 cintres avec les
incubateurs locaux des collectivités
locales éventuellement des mécanismes
incitatifs comme le crédit impôt
recherche dont il convient encore une
fois d'éviter les déviances dans
l'utilisation que certains peuvent en
faire est d'essayer de faire monter
comme ça des pépites
ça vient pas d'en bas dans le numérique
ça peut plus venir d'en bas sont des
plateformes et ça viendra nécessairement
voilà de 2,2 de ce terrain avec ses ces
entreprises françaises qui encore une
fois se fonde sur une excellence
française qu'on nous envie et ce n'est
pas simplement la question de la taille
israël est un formidable pays en matière
de création numérique
il souhaite un grand pays d'édition
logicielle et simplement c'est la
manière dont on se projette sur
l'international qui est tout à fait
essentiel ce que j'évoquais son
programme bizspark
on est des startups à venir
l'international le marché français est
trop étroit cet égard c'est le marché
européen et le marché mondial
comment on crée cette logique
partenariale c
elle dans laquelle on s'est inscrits des
grands groupes des pme des collectivités
locales où la puissance publique
nationale peuvent travailler ensemble
pour développer un écosystème
c'est comme cela que ça fonctionnera
c'est pas en fermant le marché c'est en
l'ouvrant quels sont les déviances du
crédit impôt recherche que vous avez
cité monsieur mots c'est par exemple
celle que j'ai eue dans les rapports
parlementaires
vous êtes bien informé très concrètement
revenons un peu la fiscalité si je fais
10 h à d'euros sur le e-commerce ou 10h
à dans les circuits habituels
au niveau fiscal et une différence
j'imagine ça se passe pas des manières
donc qu'on se concernant google un
annonceur qui qui dépenseraient 10 euros
pour acheter de la publicité sur une des
pages de recherche de google
il ya en fait pas de différence avec un
autre support dans la mesure où donc là
c'est ce qui est en jeu c'est la tva
dans la mesure où c'est une relation ce
qu'on appelle 'b to b' entre autres
professionnels et donc dans ce cas là
google ne facture pas la tv irlandaise
c'est l'annonceur qui dans son auto
liquidation de tva appliquant fait la
tva française
sur la fiscalité on a parlé des
entreprises on a bien compris que pour
vous c'est un critère de compétitivité
sur les individus est ce que ces
chercheurs ce ce bouillonnement qui
vient est ce que ça peut être une
préoccupation la fiscalité la fiscalité
est ce que vous avez d'ores et déjà des
à un sentiment quelque chose sur ce plan
là ça ne produit pas pour l'instant je
veux dire que j'ai convaincre un
ingénieur basé à zurich de venir
travailler à paris c'est un sujet fait
qu on est on a besoin de faire des
calculs évidemment pour les convaincre
il ya un deuxième élément ji-yai les
chercheurs et j'étais vendredi dernier à
sophia antipolis
à l'invitation du sénateur il la fit est
ce qui nous semble c'est le génie et la
le capital développement et là c'est le
capital d'amorçage qui n'est pas là
c'est à dire en voix face à ce
foisonnement et cette richesse créative
des ingénieurs français
une difficulté dans toute la partie
amorçage c'est à dire trouver 5 millions
d'euros c'est facile trouver 50 mille
euros c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
je voyais chez microsoft n'y a pas de
problème sur ce plan là pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de problème est ce qu'il ya
des dix est exact pire que ce à quoi il
faut s'atteler c'est la capacité
développement les programmes que qu'on a
monté c'est effectivement la possibilité
pour un ensemble de start-up d'entrée en
lien avec des capitaux risqueurs et on
sait qu'en france il y a moins de
capitaux risqueurs d'ailleurs en
fonction des capitaux risqueurs et c'est
plutôt des capitalistes d' aventure aux
états unis le mot est un petit peu est
un petit peu
il révélateur mais il ya beaucoup moins
en france qu'en angleterre ou aux états
unis de capitaux risqueurs à cet égard
donc c'est là qu'on trouve une
difficulté qui est sans doute
pénalisante
si je peux ajouter un point également
tout à fait essentielle pour des start
up notamment au delà du chercheur qui
cherche qui va je cherche qui trouverait
ses visions disait ça très bien les
chercheurs qui qui trouvent on en
cherche chercheurs qui cherche on trouve
mais le fêter et ça c'est tout à fait
essentiel c'est que pour une startup la
stabilité du cadre juridique et fiscal
la prévisibilité sont des éléments tout
à fait essentiel la sécurité juridique
et la prévisibilité sont des éléments
essentiels lorsqu'on fait un business
plan
lorsqu'on veut se projeter lorsqu'on
veut attirer des ddd capitaux lorsqu'on
veut faire des tours de table un
changement permanent de la loi du
règlement de l'environnement légal et
réglementaire
c'est pénalisant c'est pénalisant et je
pense que cet élément là doit tout à
fait être présent à l'esprit lorsqu'on
parle de ce sujet
oui sur le taux d'imposition quel est le
taux effectif d'imposition pour vos deux
groupes en france et dans les pays
étrangers on a parlé l'irlande mais on
n'a pas forcément parler les autres pays
est ce que vous avez des éléments
chiffrés là-dessus précis
en france pour ce qui concerne google
france sarl dans la chiffre d'affaires
s'est élevé à 68 millions d'euros
nous avons payé un peu moins de 30
millions d'euros de taxes et d'impôts en
le groupe google inc donc là le chiffre
qui est public
ces 21 % de taux d'imposition et
microsoft
et je ne vais je ne vais pas vous donner
les chiffres consolidés de toutes les
taxes parce que il faut que je regarde
ces chiffres exacts je peux vous donner
liesse mais je pouvais les communiquer
je peux vous donner la masse salariale
avec également la participation
je voudrais tous ces chiffres
précis qui sont pour l'essentiel au delà
de ce qu'on vient d'entendre ont les
vins pour 21% de google liesse
représente quel par là dessus sur les 30
millions d'euros en france et pour la
part france donc ça fait combien ça vaut
mieux ça fait 8 millions et 8 plus
toutes les taxes afférentes aux
rémunérations et à la partie sociale
d'accord dernière question pour m'avoir
excusez-moi vendanges et la porter du
coup je m'isole liesse nous chercher
rizzoli liesse pour l'année 2011 ces 21
millions six cent soixante dix huit
mille 455 euros et la masse salariale
incluant la participation est de 141
millions hélas pour l'imposition je ne
parle que de liesse et qui est passé en
fait de 14 millions en 2008 à 21
millions en 2011
ça n'est que lles évidemment il faut y
ajouter tous les éléments que je vous
indiquerai nous sommes sur un modèle de
commission coup plus ce pourcentage des
ventes de miolles en france et qui est
parmi les plus les plus élevés le 21
pour cent taux d'imposition c'est bien
google inc
selon les documents remis à la sec au à
la 6e' aux états unis
rien donc ses voeux tout le monde
et concernant google
la presse a évoqué des démarches de
l'administration fiscale avec
l'hypothèse de redressements fiscaux
devant parler de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros
de façon générale sur quelle base
juridique ou factuelles une entreprise
multinationale peut-elle contester
l'existence en france d'un établissement
stable et la réalisation d'un entre
guillemets cycle commercial complet
alors il faut avouer que c'est une
question qui dépasse mais mes
compétences dans le domaine de la
fiscalité
en revanche je peux vous confirmer qu'il
n'y a pas eu de redressement fiscal pour
google en france
c'est sur l'administration il ya une
transaction il ya un dialogue en cours
un contrôle en cours
voilà
oui tout à l'heure vous est tout ouïe et
tout à l'heure vous avez j'étais attiré
par une de vos réflexions et dick nous
avons pas de problème pour trouver cinq
cent mille euros mais des difficultés
pour trouver 50000 euros alors ma
question c'est quel faudrait-il faire
sur le plan législatif dans notre pays
en france pour encourager des capitaux
risqueurs à aider les tpe à venir en
aide aux tpe oui effectivement mon
constat de dun de terrain et fréquentant
les incubateurs les start up et et y
compris les fonds d'investissement
m'amène à à faire ce commentaire sur les
dispositions à prendre pour encourager
cet investissement qui doit être
considérée comme un investissement de
davanture positive et pas comme un
investissement de risques je veux dire
que là ça dépasse mes compétences mais
j'ai rencontré nous avons eu la visite
il ya deux mois du premier investisseur
qui a mis les cinquante mille premiers
dollars dans google voilà c'est le sujet
c'est ça c'est pour nous on était
plusieurs à vouloir le faire mais en
tous les cas ce que je fais partie de
clubs technologique nous entendons
toujours la même ancien c'est à dire on
me remet gellé capital-développement
maintenant qu'ils me proposent des
millions d'euros c'est pas maintenant
j'en ai besoin
j'en avais besoin de beaucoup moins au
tout début c'est ce qu'on entend quand
sur la base du projet etalab nous créons
un une compétition ne nous aussi à
l'instar de ce que fait microsoft pour
que des développeurs créent à partir des
données publiques et je l'espère
s'enrichissent c'est aussi ce que nous
renvoie ses développeurs je suis désolé
de ne pas pouvoir apporter de
contribution plus importante
très bien mais messieurs il me reste à
vous remercier pour votre contribution
aux travaux de notre commission et vous
nous avez éclairer sur
activités numériques et ses perspectives
moi aussi
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sur l'évasion fiscale pour
revoir ses auditions notre site internet
publicsenat.fr à suivre l'émission
politique de la rédaction de public
c'est la preuve par trois bonne fin de
journée à tous
à